Christian Rupprecht hält den langen
Leidensweg seiner Tochter in den Händen
eine mutkette jede Perle eine Behandlung
Chemo Blutabnahme Spritzen es sind viele
die die kleine Hanna sammeln musste hier
in der Kinder Onkologie in Regensburg
ist schwer aber
seine Tochter ist fünf Jahre alt seit
Juli ist sie mit ihrem Vater hier auf
Station hanna ist dann Leukämie erkrankt
bereits zum zweiten Mal ihre Kolben muss
weit bis möglich ist und soweit wie es
geht und vor dem Herzen eigentlich sehr
zufrieden und er sei froh dass Hanna
überhaupt hier sein kann denn
Personalmangel hoher Krankenstand
herrscht auch hier die Folge wenig
Betten zu wenig insgesamt zehn für
schwerkranke Kinder und Jugendliche
immer wieder müssen sie kleine Patienten
auch ablehnen
und auf der emotional hoher Druck weil
man natürlich alles Gefühl hat
man möchte allen Patienten gerecht
werden und sie bestmöglich versorgen es
reiche hinten und vorne einfach nicht
sagt Christoph Bauer hinzu kommt der
finanzielle Druck die Abrechnung
überfallpauschalen die die Kosten der
intensiven Betreuung bei weitem nicht
decken
vielleicht mit einem Automechaniker wenn
ich zu dem ein Instrument gebe zum
Beispiel eine Schraubenzieher und sagt
so jetzt repariertes Auto das
funktioniert nicht trotz der oft
schweren Diagnosen sind die Aussichten
für die Krebskranken kleinen Patienten
meist sehr gut 80 bis 90% der Kinder
könnten die Kliniken heute Gehalt
verlassen so der Leiter der Regensburger
Kinder Onkologie Selim Gorbatschow Klo
und doch müsste er sich täglich
schmerzlich mit der Frage
auseinandersetzen was sind uns unsere
Kinder Wert es ist frustrierend betteln
zu müssen wenn es das Bild unsere
Gesellschaft ist das unsere Kinder quasi
als Anhängsel irgendwo mitgestreift
werden weil sie sich nicht wehren können
das ist eigentlich solchen Armutszeugnis
ein Armutszeugnis ist es auch dass sie
bei der Anschaffung von wichtigen
medizinischen Geräten auf die Spenden
der Eltern angewiesen sind weil kein
Geld da ist wie etwa für diesen Laser
der die Nebenwirkungen der Chemo spürbar
lindert
47.000 Euro hat er gekostet
bezahlt von einem Verein der sich um
krebskranke Kinder und ihre Eltern
kümmert für Irmgard schärübel früher
selbst betroffen ist es ein Skandal das
für die kleinen Patienten nicht genügend
Geld da ist die Kinder die sind das
wichtigste die dass wir überhaupt haben
und dann müssten sie auch das wichtigste
im Gesundheitswesen sein und nicht an
letzte Stelle stehen kinder sind keine
kleinen Erwachsenen Kinder haben
Bedürfnisse ganz spezielle Bedürfnisse
Irmgard schärübel weiß wovon sie spricht
ihr Sohn war vor Jahren ein Krebs
erkrankt längst ist der geheilt doch
dieses Gefühl damals das vergisst sie
nie
erstmal ja Schockstarre man weiß einfach
gar nicht wie was man fangen soll mit
der Diagnose wo man Hilfe holen kann wie
es weitergehen soll umso schlimmer sei
es wenn Eltern und Kinder in so einer
verzweifelten Lage auch noch bangen
müssen richtig behandelt zu werden die
Situation in Regensburg kein Einzelfall
bundesweit klagen die Kinderkliniken
über die katastrophale Situation jede
zweite muss Patienten sogar wegschicken
weil sie kein freies Bett mehr hat so
eine aktuelle Umfrage unter intensiv und
notfallmedizinern die Lage ist höchst
dramatisch denn wir müssen den ganzen
Tag überlegen eben wenn da ein Bett ist
welcher Patient bekommt es und welcher
eben auch nicht das bedeutet also auch
dass wir nicht sicher wissen ob wir
wirklich allen Kindern die für uns
wünschenswerte beste Behandlung zukommen
lassen können auch im harnischen
Kinderspital in München sind sie längst
am Limit neben dem Personalmangel
verschärfen Influenza und das Kassieren
der R Virus die ohnehin angespannte
Situation
seit etwa zwei Wochen sei die Anzahl der
Erkrankungen spürbar gestiegen und kaum
zu stemmen so der kinderinfektiologe
Ulrich von both die Situation ist hier
das auch in der Notaufnahme teilweise
über Nacht Patienten Mütter mit ihren
Kindern Väter mit ihren Kindern
übernachten aus lauter Verzweiflung denn
die Stationen sind voll hier können aus
personalmangelstadt 18 sowieso nur zehn
Kinder aufgenommen werden täglich muss
Ulrich von Boot mit seinem Team
entscheiden welche Kinder sie aufnehmen
können und welche nicht aus der
Notaufnahme können wir natürlich selten
alle Kinder hier oben aufnehmen das
heißt RSV ist leider auch oft zu Hause
obwohl er vielleicht hier behandelt
werden müsste das heißt es würde eng und
es ist sehr eng der zweijährige henry
hat einen Herzfehler dazu noch das
RS-Virus mit einer Lungenentzündung seit
seiner Geburt muss Nicole frömmingen
immer wieder alle hoffen und bangen dass
ihr Sohn die nötige Behandlung bekommt
das haben wir letztes Jahr schon
erfahren müssen wo er diese Herz-OP
brauchte da waren wir im Deutschen
Herzzentrum da war es auch ganz schön
mit dem die haben die die hätten die
Kapazitäten da die könnten jeden Tag
viel mehr Kinder operieren aber die
haben halt nicht das Personal und die
Betten dazu betreuen Eltern absagen zu
müssen die sehnsüchtig auf geplante
Behandlungen ihrer kranken Kinder warten
Silke Westermeier muss diese schlechten
Nachrichten immer häufiger überbringen
ja bitte man ist halt persönlich auch im
Zwiespalt weil man sich denkt na ja dann
wenn jemand ausfällt arbeite ich lieber
bevor man noch mal im Bett spielen muss
sie tun alles und die Kinder gut zu
versorgen und doch scheint es nie zu
erreichen
die kleinen trifft es mit voller Wucht
von ihnen wird besonders viel abverlangt
zu der Vater eines Patienten
da muss eine infusionsander sieht man
das in der Notaufnahme momentan sehr
viel los ist und sehr lange Wartezeiten
sind bis zu zehn Stunden mussten wir mal
warten und die ersten Schwestern tun
schon das bestmögliche wirklich aber
es die können auch nicht mehr und wer
ein Bett hat der will es ungern aufgeben
wie bei Anna die zweijährige hat Krebs
sechs Monate war sie hier auf der
onkologischen Station heute wird sie
entlassen doch in die Freude mischt sich
auch die Angst ihrer Eltern
wenn wir zu Hause sein und müssten dann
herzwegs Fieber dann wissen wir nicht ob
wir hier auf der Station aufgenommen
werden können weil die Betten reduziert
sind die Sorge ist berechtigt denn auch
hier ist im Moment alles dicht nichts
geht mehr wegen Personalmangel können
auch hier viele Betten nicht belegt
werden das bedeutet dass wir hier in der
Onkologie
unsere Kinder nicht mehr versorgen
können also wir können die Familien die
wir lange lange kennen bei uns auf
Station zum Teil nicht mehr aufnehmen
doch es ist nicht nur die aktuelle
Situation die die Kliniken in Bedrängnis
bringen die Entwicklung bahne sich schon
seit langem an er ist frustriert dass
man den Eindruck hat dass man über Jahre
nicht gehört wird
dass man ja auch nicht nachlassen kann
weil unsere unsere Kinder die volle
Hingabe verdient haben es ist es ist
frustrierend und doch regt sich auch
hier Hoffnung die Abschaffung der
pauschalen und die 300 Millionen
euro-spritze durch das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium sein erste
wichtige Schritte zum Wohle der Kinder
zurück auf die onkologische
Kinderstation der Uniklinik Regensburg
Lagebesprechung mitten rein ein Anruf
vor dem sich derzeit die meisten
Kinderkliniken fürchten ein Notfall doch
die Station ist voll nichts geht mehr
was heißt das jetzt
das ist eigentlich unser täglich Bruder
wegschicken müssen vertrösten müssen im
schlimmsten Fall bedeutet es denn den
Todes natürlich
Kinder müssen sterben weil es kein Platz
im Krankenhaus für sie gibt ein Albtraum
auch für die Menschen die hier arbeiten
und ich fühle mich damit schlecht nicht
ausreichend Betten zu haben nicht
ausreichend Pflegekräfte zu haben die
die Kinder versorgen den Krebs wartet
nicht
nach langem Hin und Her telefonieren
finden Sie ein Bett für den kleinen
Notfallpatienten in einer anderen Klinik
und die kleine Hanna sie darf über
Weihnachten nach Hause zu ihrer Mutter
und den beiden Brüdern die sie sehr
vermisst und die nächsten kleinen
Patienten sie warten schon
[Musik]